bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
premier numéro du 7-8 culture au
sommaire de ce mercredi 7 septembre le
mois molière fêtait ses 20 ans en juin
dernier une exposition des archives
communales retrace son histoire à
travers documents photos et costumes
d'époque
le tatouage et les bijoux sont une
tradition chez les femmes berbères une
artiste vit sinoise partage à travers
ses toiles une tradition familiale et
les 26 27 et 28 août dernier c'était le
festival rock en seine
trois jours de concerts où se sont
croisés groupes internationaux et
franciliens et cette année donc le mois
molière fête ses 20 ans une occasion
pour les archives de la ville de
proposer une exposition retraçant
l'histoire du festival
elle est habilitée depuis le 3 septembre
aux archives communales
une première découverte grâce à des
images de camille lambert depuis 1996 le
dramaturge règne sur versailles le mois
molière à 20 ans 20 ans de souvenirs de
spectacles et d'artistes rassemblés dans
une exposition avec en pièce maîtresse
la première affiche du festival
elle a été réalisé par un étudiant de
l'école des beaux-arts et elle a donc
été reprise pour les deux premières
éditions 96 et 1997 et elle figure le
portrait de molière qui évidemment le
personnage emblématique qui a
constituer le coeur de ce premier
festival et son portrait et sa signature
sont au coeur du tissu urbain un petit
peu comme un manifeste de l'importance
du territoire et de sa population pour
la pérennité et l'identité de ce
festival pas de subi chronologique les
temps forts sont présentés de manière
thématique l'histoire du festival se
découvre à travers costumes et masques
de compagnies en résidence mais aussi
ses sites
la ville au départ en 81 96 n'avaient
pas de lieu de
capacité suffisante pour accueillir des
spectateurs aussi nombreux et à partir
de 1998 l'aide du château a été
extrêmement important puisque il a mis à
disposition de la ville
la cour delà de la grande écurie qui est
devenu vraiment sa cour d'honneur une
sorte d' épices en fête du festival dans
laquelle les plus grands spectacles en
majorité d'ailleurs gratuits sont sont
présentés
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'à la
fin du mois de septembre le mois molière
écrira ensuite un nouveau chapitre de
son histoire le musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines fait peau
neuve
la réhabilitation des bâtiments a permis
d'intégrer le musée aurait jo au rez de
chaussée de la médiathèque accueille en
commun locaux partagés il devrait
occuper une surface de 400 mètres carrés
les travaux vont se poursuivre jusqu'à
la mi septembre pour une réouverture
prévue le 16 novembre le responsable de
la réhabilitation auprès de 50 ans jean
stéphane spira nous donne les détails
des différents espaces du musée
donc ça c'est un plan du musée
la ici on à l'accueil du musée on aura
un petit espace de projection avec un
écran et puis des petits gradins pour
projeter un petit peu le l'histoire du
musée et puis du de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a ici une partie d'exposition
permanente et deux salles d'exposition
temporaire unis si tout en longueur et
une carré par ici
la violence la douleur la séduction ou
encore la malédiction
ce sont plusieurs symbolique qu'on peut
retrouver dans les tatouages berbère
fatima binet-ouakka une artiste vie
chinoise expose des toiles inspirées
d'une tradition familiale d'une histoire
aussi ancestrale dans son maroc natal
l'exposition est à découvrir à la
médiathèque antoine de saint-exupéry de
voisins le bretonneux
petit aperçu une croix pour les jambes
et les bras de l'homme
un point pour le foyer autant de
symbolique que les femmes berbères se
tatouent une tradition transmise à
fatima binet-ouakka par sa propre
famille
c'est pas innocent c'est parce que je
rends hommage à offin de mon bled
l'anglais qui s'appelle ait cdn à 60 km
de fès dans les moyen atlas
ces femmes c'est ma grand mère ma mère
mes tantes qui ont travaillé les tapis
qui en était à tous et et qui sont aussi
libres des corps en mouvement sur
lesquels l'artiste montre ce qu'elle
nomme des scarifications des tatouages
sur le haut du corps auquel s'ajoute le
real lourds bijoux de cheville ce bijou
il intègre la personnalité de ces femmes
il n'est plus externe
il est plus interne malgré sa lourdeur
et petit à petit vous imaginer ce
qu'elle est devenue le crash c'est la
chaînette convoi au pied aujourd'hui
corps à corps est une invitation au
voyage historique et traditionnel
proposé jusqu'au mois de novembre
et pour compléter ce voyage l'atteindre
et dédicace son ouvrage tout heureuse
porteuse d'espoir le samedi 17 septembre
à 15 heures là aussi à la médiathèque
l'an dernier il obtenait le prix du
public du festival d'un ural cette année
encore les élèves du conservatoire de
montigny le bretonneux sont invités dans
le morvan pour participer au concours de
trompes l'oeil ils ont choisi cette
année de rendre hommage aux pompiers de
des années 1920 1930 les fresques sont
un terreau est menée sur place durant le
week-end des 10 et 11 septembre
nous avons rencontré les peintres avant
leur départ on les écoute le trompe
l'oeil c'est l'art de représenter les
espaces grandeur nature en trichant un
type avec des lumières et la perspective
pour pouvoir
en caricaturant un tout petit peu pour
pouvoir faire voir à l'oeil ce qu'on
veut qu'ils voient le trompe l'oeil
c'est pas du de l'hyperréalisme c'est
quand même quelque chose qu'on voit au
minimum deux mètres de distance donc
avec un recul
chaque semaine les professionnels du
cinéma saint quentinois nous donneront
leurs coups de coeur des sorties de la
semaine
et cette semaine c'est siri la date de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois écouter cette semaine
notre coup de coeur et le film coréen
dernier train pour bizane un virus
inconnu serait pas en corée du sud
l'état d'urgence est décrété les
passagers du train ktx se livrent à une
lutte sans merci afin de survivre
jusqu'à fusad l'unique ville où ils
seront en sécurité
mené tambour battant ce thriller hyper
efficace alterne entre scènes ultra
spectaculaires ou des ordres de zombies
envahissent l'écran et des séquences de
huit clos étouffante
notons que le réalisateur propose aux
spectateurs une mise en scène inventive
avec une touche d'humour
ces derniers ne le regretteront vraiment
participent présenté en séance de minuit
au dernier festival de cannes le film a
fait hurler de terreur les festivaliers
cette petite pépite du septième art
coréen s'impose déjà comme un grand film
du genre interdit aux moins de 12 ans
dernier train pour buse anne est proposé
en version française et originale et est
à découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret
et de rendez vous à noter dans votre
agenda culturel à la royale factory
vendredi 9 et samedi 17 ans il sera
question de fables et de poésie
lafontaine at il du flou booba vaut-il
baudelaire réponse avec de la fontaine à
booba et le théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance sa
saison le samedi 24 septembre avec aubry
gîte brigitte fontaine et les musiques à
ouïr revisite les succès de la reine des
kékés on regarde un extrait
mais je m'en vais ce notre m
et sansan vie se divertir
deux filles modèles
la recherche du temps perdu
je sais là
une affaire
et là s'en faut
vous
vingt places sont à gagner pour assister
à ce concert si vous êtes intéressé
direction la page facebook de tv fil 78
pour connaître les conditions et on
termine avec un retour sur l'un des
événements culturels de cette fin d'été
en ile de france
rock en seine dans le domaine de saint
cloud en marge des têtes d'affiché de
cette année dit guy pop assomme fortiweb
le festival a fait la part belle aux
artistes en devenir
ils étaient une douzaine à venir de la
région et à se produire sur scène vous
de friedrich y est allé à leur rencontre
rock en seine plus de cent dix mille
visiteurs sur trois jours venus braver
un dernier week-end d'août caniculaire
dans le parc du domaine de saint-cloud
rendez-vous qui depuis presque quinze
ans permettent au détour des allées de
constater l'engouement des franciliens
pour les cours de danse avec une dizaine
de leçon au programme encadrés par des
professionnels
les vinyles également à l'honneur avec
le désormais traditionnel village des
disquaires mercun scène c'est surtout
des moments d'anthologie avec cette
année le presque septuagénaire iggy pop
en tête d'affiche pour 2016 le festival
s'est une nouvelle fois ouvert aux
autres genres musicaux notamment le rap
et casseurs flotteurs sont venus est
achevé leur tournée estivale
dernier coup d'éclat après un film et
une série télé regarde regarde le
regarde le poteau comme à côté il a une
tronche de rappeurs et nous on est dans
un show nerveux qui serait je pense
qu'ils s'équipent qu'il ya des
connivences avec le l'énergie rock on
ramène le rap à l'ancienne
on amorce une transition là c'est le
dernière datar concernent des casseurs
fait trois ans qu'on bosse le projet
casseurs et là on sent qu'on a on en a
les tirs et le projet dans tous les sens
et qu'on on pourrait risquer soul et les
gens si on continue et puis ce sont mme
haird et nous les premiers
et derrière on a plein de projets solos
les uns les autres claude prépare son
premier album l'album effet il n'ya plus
qu'à le masterisé maintenant on va
commencer à envoyer un clip à la rentrée
merci en marge des artistes confirmés
des talents en devenir rock en seine en
festivals pour promouvoir musiciens et
chanteurs franciliens débutants la
région principal partenaire ainsi sa
propre scène chaque année et c'était une
douzaine à s'y produire pour cette
édition tim dunn à 21 ans il est
originaire de rambouillet fait j'ai
rencontré mes managers qui sont un
directeur de le mba sannois dans le 95
dans le val d'oise est en fait battre
c'est notamment avec eux que j'ai eu
j'ai pu avoir un programme
d'accompagnement notamment avec arcady
qui fonctionne aussi avec la région ile
de france
en tout cas pour moi
des programmes et là sur la scène ile de
france est une nouvelle étape
ce changement par istres tant que tu
traverses quand tu prends tu es
parmi les autres artistes issus de l'île
de france ti hoyaux et son mélange de
soul de blues et de rock des années 70
il ad'abord rôder dans les couloirs du
métro lui aussi a bénéficié d'une aide
de la région qui lui a permis de
réaliser des premières parties
d'artistes majeurs
et pour réussir il s'est également pris
en main en allant se produire aux états
unis ouais ça m'a donné une force aussi
de devoir voir si c'est jouer là-bas
pouvoir rencontrer des gens et échanger
avec eux et écoliers ce feeling qui
passe quoi tu vois c'est ça m'a permis
de me dire que je pouvais revenir ici et
par mon truc
poissonsla au brésil
au total l'île de france compterait plus
de 20000 groupes de musiques actuelles
la région on tombe bien valoriser cette
richesse et toutes nos stratégies
culturelles qu'on va dévoiler en
septembre elle est fondée sur l'idée
d'inclusion inclusion c'est quoi ça veut
dire que dans un quartier populaire dans
une zone rurale au fin-fond l'île de
france
eh bien on peut devenir soi-même acteurs
culturels et on peut aussi avoir accès à
la culture
et l'an prochain la région sera une
nouvelle fois présente sur le festival
rock en seine aux groupes régionaux de
se montrer à la hauteur et de ne pas
hésiter de d2
le cetud culture est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine